well there's about three different size
of this the old one is of course the old
cliche land of poverty suffering the
begging bowl the naked fakir on this bed
of nails I mean that those images the
snake charmer that that image of India
which i think is gradually being
supplanted but it has to lay a hold on
the popular imagination because it was
drilled into people's minds and eyes for
four decades if not centuries and that
image is being gradually dispelled I
think by the the new India of software
geeks and computer gurus maybe that's
changing but that's certainly one image
that I'd like to dispel the second image
is perhaps the paradoxical one of the
land that's stealing away American jobs
there's now an increasing sense of jobs
being outsourced to Bangalore you know
people get laid off and say I'd be in
Bangalore in fact India has only created
1 million IT jobs in the last 10 years
and during that time America has shed 3
million jobs but each of those 3 million
Americans is looking at those 1 million
jobs in India and saying that's my job
so there is that that sense of of
stereotyping of misunderstanding which I
think needs to be dispelled both because
it's not true but also because it plays
into a very negative and unconstructive
view of today's globalization which i
think which i think is worth worth
defending in the interests of Americans
and Indians and the third set of images
probably is of exotic India the land of
yoga and of course the movies of
Bollywood and the the ashrams and
retreats where people can go and sit in
the Himalayas and meditate that sort of
image got a boost really in the late 60s
with the Beatles going off and learning
Transcendental Meditation from Hiroshima
yogi and from then on you've had the
likes of Madonna and Goldie Hawn going
off
yeah you've had Richard Gere discovering
that a llama in India you've had a set
of set opening up to this spirituality
and otherworldly yearnings that come
from Indian experience now that's not a
bad thing in fact each of these three
stereotypes has some kernel of truth and
I don't want to deny that poverty is
real there are 260 million Indians gonna
live on I live on the wrong side of a
poverty line that's been drawn just the
side of the funeral pyre so that's it's
real but it's being overcome and the
other India isn't sufficiently known the
second cliche as I said yes some jobs
are being created in India that were
lost in America but it's not the whole
story and third on the in the exotic ISM
and the spirituality and the other
worldliness that's true too we have more
than our fair share of of gurus and
Godman and seekers of truth and so on
and we do have something to offer the
people who want to look for that kind of
truth back in India but having said that
it's also true to say that India is in
many ways not that different from any
other country in the world that's full
of people who are trying to make a
living give their kids a decent
education get three meals a day put a
roof over their heads try and achieve
some kinds of conventional aspirations
in life including financial and material
security and that aspect of India as a
normal society going beyond the cliches
of the three kinds of stereotypes I
described to you it's something that I
would like people to be more conscious
of and I think in America the increasing
numbers of Indian Americans now to about
three million in this country it's
beginning to change that for the better
because when you see Indians our folks
just like you a dress like you would
talk like you would like you but they're
Indian and they go back to families or
at least at the very least ancestors and
relatives in India that changes the way
you think about India too and I think
that's a bit possible